MOB OFF A CLIFF BECAUSE OF
FACTS, REASON, INTELLECT, AND
SOMETHING CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION.
HE IS HERE TO RESPOND.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF "GUILT BY
ASSOCIATION."
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT PERHAPS
OVER THE YEARS HAVE LIKED YOU
AND RESPECTED YOU.
THIS CROSSES A LINE.
LOCKHART IN PARTICULAR CROSSES A
LINE.
REALLY?
THEY’RE GOING TO COMPARE YOU TO
HITLER?
THEY ARE GOING TO GO THAT FAR
BECAUSE YOU DARED TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION BASED ON
REALLY SOUND KNOWLEDGE, THE
CONSTITUTION, OUR FOUNDERS, OR
FRAMERS.
YOU LAID IT OUT AND THEY HATE
THE FACT THAT YOU DISAGREE WITH
THEM AND YOU ARE SO EFFECTIVE.
>> I THINK THE REASON THEY
REALLY CAME AFTER ME IS THEY SAW
AFTER I MADE MY TALK AND ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS, MANY SENATORS
GATHERED AROUND ME, INCLUDING
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ALL SAID HOME THEY WERE
IMPRESSED BY MY CONSTITUTIONAL
PRESENTATION.
THE POINT I WAS MAKING WAS ABOUT
THE SENATORS.
WHAT I SAID AS IF YOU HAVE MIXED
MOTIVES, IF YOU ARE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST AND YOU’RE
TRYING TO HELP THE PUBLIC BUT
YOU’RE ALSO TRYING TO GET
REELECTED, ACCORDING TO SCHIFF
AND NADLER, THAT’S A CRIME.
IF YOU HAVE ANY INKLING OF
MOTIVE TO HELP YOURSELF GET
REELECTED, THEY CALL IT CORRUPT
AND THEY SAY EVEN A TINY AMOUNT
OF MOTIVE TO HELP YOURSELF MAKES
YOU INTO A CRIMINAL AND MAKES
YOU IMPEACHABLE.
I TURNED TO ALL THE SENATORS AND
I SAID, EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM,
EVERY SENATOR, EVERY POLITICIAN
EVERYWHERE ALWAYS HAS ONE EYE
TOWARD REELECTION AND ANOTHER
EYE TOWARD THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
THEY ALMOST ALWAYS THINK IT’S
THE SAME.
THEY ALSO THINK THEIR OWN
ELECTION IS IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
YOU CAN’T MAKE THAT AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
I NEVER, EVER SAID OR SUGGESTED
OR IMPLIED THAT A PRESIDENT CAN
DO ANYTHING HE WANTS IF HE
THINKS HIS ELECTION WILL HELP
THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
THAT WAS JUST A LIE, A
DISTORTION.
AND IT WAS STATED BY SCHIFF.
IT WAS STATED BY NADLER.
IT WAS STATED BY SCHUMER.
IT WAS STATED BY VIRTUALLY
EVERYBODY ON CNN AND MSNBC AND
IT WAS QUICKLY FALSE.
>> Sean: AID WAS NEVER
DISCUSSED AT ALL IN THE PHONE
CALL BUT CORRUPTION WAS
DISCUSSED.
UKRAINE, THE ONLY FACT WITNESS
SAID I WANT NOTHING.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
UKRAINE GOT ALL OF THEIR MONEY.
THEY DID NOTHING.
THEY PROMISED TO DO NOTHING.
EVEN IF THE PRESIDENT SAID, I
WOULD LIKE TO PUNCH THIS GUY IN
THE FACE AND NOT GIVE HIM A
PENNY UNLESS HE DOES, B, OR SEE.
DIDN’T WORK OUT THAT WAY.
PEOPLE CAN’T BE PUNISHED FOR
THEIR THOUGHTS COME I DON’T
THINK, CAN THEY?
>> WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS THE
SAME THEORY COULD PUT JOE BIDEN
IN JAIL.
IF SOMEBODY COULD CLAIM THAT 99%
OF BIDEN’S MOTIVATION IN GETTING
PROSECUTOR FIRED WAS THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN PREVENTING
CORRUPTION, 1%, IN THE BACK OF
HIS MIND, HE WAS THINKING MAYBE
THIS COULD HELP MY SON A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE HE WORKS FOR THE
COMPANY THAT’S BEING
INVESTIGATED, ACCORDING TO
NADLER AND SHIFT, THAT WOULD BE
ENOUGH.
>> Sean: LET ME APPEAL TO YOUR
COMMON SENSE.
>>A VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES --
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS TO A COUNTRY
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR OR YOU ARE
NOT GETTING A BILLION DOLLARS IN
AID.
YOU’VE GOT SIX HOURS.
SON OF A B, THEY DID.
WHO WAS THE PROSECUTOR?
THE PROSECUTOR IS INVESTIGATING
HIS SON.
HIS SON IS NO EXPERIENCE IN
UKRAINE, OIL, GAS, OR ENERGY BUT
HE’S BEING PAID MILLIONS.
83,000 A MONTH.
AVERAGE AMERICAN FAMILY OF FOUR
MAKES LESS THAN 56,000 A YEAR.
ANYONE WHO WOULD PAY SOMEONE
WITH ZERO EXPERIENCE MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, DOES
THAT PASS THE SMELL TEST?
EVEN HUNTER SAID I DON’T KNOW
WHY THEY PAID ME.
WAS IT BECAUSE YOUR FATHER IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT?
PROBABLY.
>> IT’S CERTAINLY RELEVANT.
AND IF THEY DO GET WITNESSES, I
WOULD THINK AS A DEFENSE LAWYER,
THE FIRST WITNESS I WOULD WANT
TO CALL WOULD BE HUNTER BIDEN.
>> Sean: HANG ON ONE SECOND.
PROFESSOR, HANG ON ONE SECOND.
THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT
ADAM SCHIFF.
>> President Trump: EXTREME
LATE-TERM ABORTION BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THAT EVERY
CHILD IS A SACRED GIFT FROM GOD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW THE PARTY OF
HIGH TAXES, HIGH CRIME, OPEN
BORDERS, LATE-TERM ABORTION,
SOCIALISM, AND BLATANT
CORRUPTION.
NO MATTER HOW YOU CUT IT, THAT’S
WHAT IT IS.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS THE
PARTY OF THE AMERICAN WORKER,
THE AMERICAN FAMILY, THE
AMERICAN DREAM, AND THE LATE
GREAT ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
YOU KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
HONEST ABE.
REMEMBER I ALWAYS SAID I COULD
BE MORE PRESIDENTIAL THAN ANY
OTHER PAST PRESIDENT OTHER THAN
PERHAPS --
>> Sean: WE ARE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THIS IN A SECOND.
PROFESSOR, I WANT TO ASK YOU
THAT QUESTION, THOUGH.
CAN YOU NAME ANY COMPANY,
PROFESSOR, YOU’RE VERY SMART
MAN.
ANY COMPANY THAT WOULD EVER PAY
ANYBODY MILLIONS AND MILLIONS,
83,000 A MONTH WHEN THEY HAVE
ZERO, BY THEIR OWN ADMISSION ON
TAPE AN INTERVIEW, ZERO
EXPERIENCE.
I CAN’T THINK OF ANY COMPANY
THAT WOULD DO THAT UNLESS THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS THEIR FATHER.
>> TO BUY ACCESS.
OF COURSE.
NOBODY WOULD DOUBT THAT AND
THAT’S WHY IT’S WORTH
INVESTIGATING, AND THAT’S WHY IF
THERE WERE TO BE WITNESSES, HE
WOULD HAVE TO BE CALLED BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT WAS ENTITLED TO
SAME ON THE BASIS OF THIS
INFORMATION, DON’T YOU THINK
THIS SHOULD BE AN INVESTIGATION.
BY THE WAY, EVEN IF HE DID SAY
IT ON THE DAY THAT BIDEN
ANNOUNCED, WHEN A PERSON
ANNOUNCES FOR PRESIDENT, THAT
SUBJECTS THEM TO GREATER
SCRUTINY BY THE MEDIA, BY
EVERYBODY ELSE.
SO OF COURSE YOU’RE GOING TO GET
GREATER SCRUTINY IF YOU’RE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
INSTEAD OF HAVING BEEN JUST A
HAS-BEEN FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
YOU DON’T NEED SCRUTINY.
IF YOU’RE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE MORE SCRUTINY.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, HE DIDN’T